I got the report on you Chris you
[ __ ] weirdo what do you hate about
this guy you got to hear this
Chris wildin jerk - dude off on a boat
while surrounded by people he went on
something called a coke yacht whatever
that is
what's that well it's a disco booze
cruise so he's on a disco booze cruise
and he sees a perfect stranger there
they're looking at the Statue of Liberty
and Chris just goes up to this dude and
sticks his hand down the guy's pants and
jerks and laughs wait
what do you mean wait what do you know
it's better and in the middle of jerk
and the stranger off on the boat he
starts texting Ralph to tell him what
he's doing first of all you're amazing I
don't know how you [ __ ] text someone
while you're jerking someone was an
incredible operation I'll tell you that
but I have to be very clear so I go on
this booze cruise with Steve nawicki and
his girlfriend right so I'm like a third
wheel right and I was kind of worried
the whole night that I would never want
to talk and I'd be hanging around with
them and bumming them out right and at
one point I was coming back from the bar
and the boat is packed we're on the top
deck and people are dancing and they're
going crazy sounds horrible and it
really kind of was you're stuck on a
boat yeah
but all of a sudden it was like the sea
of people parted and I see this
beautiful man you know like that movie
weird science where they design a woman
in a computer right if I could design a
man in a computer it would look like
this guy right right and he looks at me
and he goes nice night I said yes
suddenly it is how you do it is it was a
great line at work they start talking
and and you can tell he's gay
oh yeah no he was just a little light in
his step right now and he was in the
disco booze cruise most of the guys
there I don't know what Steve was doing
there it's a great place to meet guys
evidently so we're talking and we're
hanging out and then next thing I know
we're kissing mm-hmm and and he's like
nibbling my neck and I'm sticking my
hand up his shirt and he's Howard he was
felt he had this lean long beautiful
body right and then and then we're
starboard we're on the right of the ship
and we Statue of Liberty it was a
beautiful moment that was there was
fireworks yeah I mean it was so romantic
and I was feeling really good about
being in this country and working here
and and just life was going really well
and he was sort of massaging around my
my pelvic area and I was massaging
around his and then now there's people
completely around us lately around us so
we're facing out you see you're an
immigrant it's not unusual for
immigrants to jerk off to the Statue of
Liberty
all right on the boat while everyone's
looking at the Statue of Liberty you
shove your hand down his pants well it
was a very gradual creeping down no no
and then he was by the way manipulating
me as well she's okay yeah I had to
shimmy my hand my forearm down the front
and then almost you know again people
are all around this so I'm just I'm
facing out almost as if I'm waving off
the ship as if we're leaving port and
I'm pushing down in a-milking motion and
jerking him off he's to the right of me
and then with my left hand yeah I was
texting Ralph's going oh my god you'll
never guess what's happening right now
it's the greatest night of my life
that is
it's unbelievable did you jerk him to
completion he got moist he did not
finish Jesus what kind of guy doesn't
finish well listen it was a very
precarious situation you didn't finish
did you know in fact I I was hanging to
the right and he was trying to touch me
to the left so he must have thought like
where's this guy's dick you know if you
were texting around he could have moved
his hand onto your day like a very
concentrate on well I woke up the next
day and I had like I had sent about ten
text messages saying I think I just met
my husband on the Cokie I'm a guy so we
we exchanged numbers and we took an uber
back to Herald Square together we both
got on separate trains I woke up the
next morning beaming I send them a text
about one o'clock the next day and I
have yet to hear anything